some breaking news to bring you  in relation to princess sheikh latifah  who you'll  be aware this week published some videos  from within her bathroom at home in  dubai where  she said she'd been imprisoned well the  uae embassy in london has responded by  carrying the following message from  the royal family in response to media  reports regarding  sheikh latifah they say we want to thank  those who've expressed concern for her  well-being despite the coverage  which certainly is not reflective of the  actual position  her family has confirmed that her  highness is being cared for at home  supported by her family and medical  professionals  she continues to improve and we are  hopeful she will return to public life  at the appropriate time so that is the  indication there that the  royal family in dubai believe that sheik  latifah is unwell  and being treated at home rather than as  she has claimed  on video is being held there against her  will effectively  incarcerated